اليوم لا حديثا لسكان اكييف الى عن زياره
الرئيس الاوكراني فولدومر زيلينسكي الى
واشنطن وخطابه امام غرفتي الكابتول حاولنا
ان نسجل منذ لحظات ردود افعالهم حول
الخطاب كلهم يعتبرونا هنا ان زيلانسكي بطل
بشهاده الجميع لانه استطاع اقناع الكونغرس
الامريكي بتقديم مساعدات ماليه لاوكرانيا
خاصه في هذه الظروف المعقده هنا في
اوكرانيا تذكر جيدا ان احدى السيدات قالت
انها لم تصوت في البدايه للزلز لكن الان
كل عائلتها تساند وتدعم كل خيارات وقرارات
كهذا في ما يخص سيارات زي الاسكيب الحديث
عن الاوضاع هنا يمكن القول اليوم في اكياف
الجميع سعداء بها باقناع بقناع واشنطن همم
دعميها او تقديمها لمنظومه الدفاع ارض جو
باتريوت الذي التي عفوا يعتقد الجميع هنا
في اوكرانيا انها من شانها ان تغير بعض
الشيء من اوضاع الحرب خاصه كيف اصبحت
تستهدف بسهوله وبدقه في اكثر من مره سواء
بصواريخ او طائرات المسيره مما يعطل جميع
المحطات توزيع وتوليد الكهرباء وهنا هذا
بالحديث عن زياره زنسكي همم اذا تحدثنا عن
الاوضاع اليوم فاكيف يمكن ان نقول الى حد
الساعه هي هادئه جدا مقارنه بليله امثله
انطلقت فيها صافرت الانذار اكثر من ثلاث
مرات امرنا باللجوء الى القبور هناك تحدث
مع الكثير من الاوكرانيين على ما يبدوا ان
الوضع اصبح روتينيا عاديه واصبحوا يتعودون
على هذا الوضع صفيرات انذار في الليل
وصفيرات انذار في النهار ليله امس ايضا
تحدث مع ايحاء احد مسيري شركات الشركات
الكبرى لتوزيعه الكهرباء هنا في اوكرانيا
يقول انهم اصبحوا عاجزين تماما امام هذا
الوضع المعقد على ايصال الكهرباء الى
البيوت وحتى الى المستشفيات والمؤسسات
الاولويه مثل المدارس والم سنه الامنيه
يعتمدون كثيرا على المساعدات الغربيه
المستعجله التي من المفروض ان تصل في خلال
الثلاث اشهر القادمه يقول مسير هذه الشركه
ان لم تصل هذه المساعدات فسوف يقضي
الاوكرانيون شتاء بارد قارس ومعقد جدا على
كل اليوميات سكان
يعني في الليل بعد الساعه الرابعه عندما
يختفي ضوء النهار هنا في اكياف يتجول سكان
المدينه بالمصابيح اليدويه لان همم التيار
الكهربائي مقطوع والماء ايضا مقطوع همم من
اجل قضاء حاجيته وفي النهار رحله البحث عن
الماء همم يعني رحله معقده جدا على كل مع
كل هذه التعقيدات والماسات همم سكان كيف
لم يخسر نهائيا همم ابتسامه ما زالوا
يحافظون على معنوياتهم ويقولون انه
بامكانههم الصمود لوجه همم في وجه
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه لكنهم لا يخفون
ايضا خشيتهم وتخوفهم من تكرر العمليات
الميدينيه من الحدود البيلاروسيه